Donald Trump is selected one of the best
known climate change deniers to lead his
Environmental Protection Agency
transition team according to two sources
close to the Trump campaign this guy's
name is Myron Ebel he is director of the
center for energy and environment at the
very conservative competitive enterprise
institute he is going to be managing
Trump's transition plan for the EPA he
is a well-known and very polarizing
figure within both the energy world and
the environment world he's known for
writing about uh alarmism as he calls
what climate change science is he
frequently appears in media he
frequently appears in front of Congress
he's chairman of the cooler heads
coalition imagine that out quite a name
a group of nonprofits that question
alarmism around climate science if you
think climate change is a hoax
perpetrated by the Chinese as Donald
Trump has said on at minimum one
occasion it does sort of follow that you
would select someone from the 0.3%
rather than the ninety nine point seven
percent on the issue of climate change
this is like choosing someone from the
tiny percentage of people who question
evolution to head up the I don't know
evolution committee if there were one to
make an analogy this is not making huge
headlines but it really confirms that a
Donald Trump presidency would actually
be as terrible as we fear there's this
idea among some that we don't really
need to worry about a trump presidency
because some of the stuff he's not going
to be able to do and in the end the
president can't really do that much
pudding and out and out climate science
denier to transition the EPA is a
disaster Trump would be able as I've
mentioned to select Supreme Court
justices in all likelihood this is an
absolute disaster and if you select a
climate-science denier to transition the
EPA you should be able to put aside
anything else that Trump
said or claimed he will do and realize
that this decision alone should uniquely
and singularly disqualify Donald Trump
from being the president of the United
States but it is barely even making
headlines and this is like I I mean I'm
trying to think of an analogy would we
put someone to head up NASA that denies
that the Sun is the center of our solar
system I hope not I really hope that we
wouldn't and that's the equivalent that
we're talking about here by selecting
Myron able to transition the EPA the
damage that Trump could cause in four
years would be incomprehensibly
far-reaching and this is just one piece
of evidence that suggests that